bruce arians there it is upper left back
super bowl
55. man of my word when we win the super
bowl i will get a tattoo well i got mine
i
love it i would at least want mine in
the spot where i can see it he's never
going to be able to see it and even if
you can somehow see it in a mirror
unless you do double mirror it's going
to be backward now chris here's my
challenge okay open challenge right
through series yeah
boss move
to get that after you win definitely but
you see where it is it's kind of left
side of the back right where do you want
him to get it
no i'm saying let's go ahead and go and
put super bowl 56 champs on there now
call your shot now babe ruth
put it on there now we've seen images
over the years of fans i remember the
guy that had the tennessee titans afc
south champions like what the hell on
his forearm and of course they didn't
win the division that year right let's
do it bruce go ahead and put the super
bowl 56 tattoo on there now rip your
shirt open and show it to the players at
the first meeting you want to keep them
from getting complacent you show them
that you've already gotten it on your
body what they're going to do
that let's see he's crazy he's not that
crazy okay that's he's not gonna do that
that's not in the coach's dna but you're
right there's been some stupid people
with that was that last year with the
the browns kid with the brown super bowl
tattoo you know that was two years ago
when they got odell right that was that
one i mean those those are things that
like we should have to relive the
internet should allow us to relive that
like hey now we're reporting in on that
weird guy who got that random tattoo two
years ago hey let's check in with him
hey how do you feel about your dumb
tattoo you got two years ago you know
what's your thoughts there uh but really
where did you want bruce arians to get
his tattoo seriously do you want to put
it on his chest on his pecs or i i would
just i would want it in a spot where i
could see it and when it's on your upper
back you're not going to see it you went
through all that pain to have that thing
put on your body and you never get to
see it i'd want to see it i'd want a
reminder i'd want it like where a watch
would be i'd want to be able to like
right next to my wristwatch i'd want the
reminder that we won the super bowl well
then no matter what i mean i look down
and i see that and i feel pretty good
yeah i hear you there i like that too i
mean i'm with you i'd want to see my
tattoo too now i mean you i don't know
if you'd really do that if you'd get it
on your arm by your wrist watch i mean
that that really i don't think you would
flaunt it like that i'm going to throw
the challenge flag on that uh but but
either way it's bold of you to say
the open invitation is there kirk
cousins super bowl envy come on kirk her
cousins make him do it
um
there have been some some fun tattoos
over the years and look people get all
sorts of crazy tattoos if they can get a
football tattoo and so what if it
happens to be a prediction that turned
out being wrong on their body it will
always be a correct prediction so maybe
that's what you should do if you're a
long-suffering fan of a team that's
never going to win a super bowl just go
ahead and get the tattoo anyway and
every time you look at your arm you can
fool yourself into thinking that it
actually did happen how about bruce
arians talking about antonio brown let's
play that sound if we have that ready
bruce erin's regarding the possibility
of brown returning seven key free agents
are back brown is still available here's
the question he was asked and his answer
i know you guys have talked with antonio
brown there's a couple outside options
as well how quickly do you see um that
getting answered and figured out here
with you guys
yeah i would you know it's going to take
our time and uh you know there's offers
out there
and um we'll see how it goes
offers out there now offers out there
that's intriguing to me does that mean
they've they've pulled off several
different concepts like what like hey
antonio we can do this on a one-year
deal we can do this on a multi-year year
two year yeah we've got offers out there
you let us know what you want to do
right and i think if they've done that
you know it maybe it's non-negotiable
it's just like hey you pick what you
want on the menu but the menu is what
the menu is yeah i i i would think so i
mean again i don't think this is
something like the buccaneers are gonna
fret about and be like oh man our team
is not the same without antonio brown so
they make an offer they probably feel
like listen what else you got out there
you know that's going to be the big
thing is anybody really going to roll
the dice or take the chance on antonio
brown i have a hard time thinking like
maybe you know i could see maybe seattle
doing that but again if you don't not
gonna have russell wilson you might
trade him in the next five weeks and
probably don't want to do that
i just think there's limited options i
expect at some point that he signs back
with the bucks here here's the concern
he's still got that pending civil
lawsuit right in florida alleging sexual
assault and rape it's not going to trial
until december but at some point he's
going to testify and if he performs in
that deposition in advance of trial like
he did in the deposition in that
that trashing of the luxury apartment
lawsuit
it's going to be a disaster and that's
going to happen at some point sooner
than later and that's not going to be
good for whoever is employing him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports